if only they were so precise on the
pitch as at their press conferences when
asked what the German offenses handicap
is at the moment termos Miller wanted to
first define the term as missing blue
green that's kind of a stupid question
you could have looked it up on Wikipedia
first I guess you mean what is the
stumbling block in our game because
handicap in golf is a way of reckoning
so that the worst player can compete
with a good one a worst player and a
good one that's not referring to Mario
Gotze and moola even though good sir as
a lone striker couldn't get much going
against the Ukraine and Poland defenders
and has since been the target of critics
does anything loose issue I know I'm not
the tallest player or the best in the
aerial game but having said that if you
look at the first chance in the Poland
game I did manage a header in porns
gives you the commission if I get the
ball into the net then it'll be a
different story rugged and Lindsay
descanso show me back muscles criticism
of their attack has trailed the world
champions all week along with talk about
a lack of leadership on the pitch and
the non-stop rain in heavy arm meanwhile
northern ireland strengths and
weaknesses are hardly mentioned seneca
Baconian attention I can't assess
Northern Ireland's handicap very well
for sure they'll keep a lot of players
in their own penalty area and if 11
players defend with team spirit and a
lot of leg work it'll be no walk in the
park but also no insurmountable obstacle
in their final group stage match Germany
have the chance to display heart and
silence their critics